our views every day a workday for you
simple answer yes every day is a workday
yeah there's a lot to do if I'm not
always in the studio I'm on the phone
I'm emailing I'm doing a ton of meetings
there's a lot of discussion talking
about what's coming up next talking
about you know the song that we're
working on talking about a scene so it's
always work what time do you normally
start your day and do you put in 8 hours
I put in more like 18 hours and I start
anywhere from you know 9:00 or 10:00 in
the morning and go till you know 10:00
or 11:00 12:00 at night sometimes into
the early morning if I'm working on a
project so it just really depends on
where I am in the phase of the project
we always hear about entrepreneurs that
they can't really turn it off they're
always working whether they're at a
restaurant and they're on quote vacation
yeah how do you how do you deal with
that as part of your life I mean yeah I
do suffer from that a little bit I as I
said I have kids so that pulls me out of
it for sure when I'm around my kids I'm
not really thinking about work at all
but it's tough if you love what you do
you want to you want to continue to get
better you want to continue to grow you
want to build at least I do so and I
love making music I love working with
the people that I work with and I'm
excited it's not work to me it's fun how
satisfied are you with your work at the
end of the day or are there times when
you're not satisfied and that's almost a
good thing because it keeps pushing you
know I think there's times when I'm
satisfied and I try not to stop a
project and tell I'm satisfied I don't
do things that I don't like I don't turn
in things that I'm not proud of so when
I'm finished with a project I'm usually
pretty satisfied I think production is a
series of compromises though sometimes
because you can't always get everything
exactly the way you want and I maybe
that's the perfectionist in me but I'm
always tinkering I'm always trying to
try something else let me try this tempo
let me try and add this instrument or
take this background vocal out or build
us bigger and but that's the fun of it
it's like
building a you know a skyscraper and
just doing anything you want just adding
another floor and adding some more
windows and just continuing to build
this amazing kind of hopefully
masterpiece and at the end of it if
you're not happy you're not proud then
you did something wrong you probably
better go back and rework it so I get a
lot of satisfaction from my finished
projects was work ethic something you
were born with or something over time
you you just picked up whether it's the
sports many new thing yeah I think it's
a combination I definitely was into
working hard but I learned a lot from my
dad who was really really a hard worker
and he preached that at home a lot you
know really dedicating yourself and
sacrificing and making the most of your
talents my mom my dad were both
musicians so they they were all about
practicing and getting better and then I
had some great coaches you know I had an
amazing high school coach John go frito
and I'm amazing college coach Lou Dolson
who's in the Basketball Hall of Fame and
those guys both showed me the meaning of
like setting a high bar setting goals
accomplishing things you don't think you
can even accomplish and expecting more
from yourself than you thought you could
do and that definitely translated to
music and I think that's something that
a lot of musicians don't have because
they didn't play sports like I played
sports my whole life since I was 7 years
old I was playing sports all the way
through college and playing in college
at that high high level you have to be
like hyper competitive and you have to
be sacrificing and intense and
goal-oriented and all the things that
you have to do to play high level
college basketball or professional
basketball those aren't things that most
musicians do so I think I brought that
to this end of what I do and I don't
know it's I think it's worked for me
haven't made too many people angry how
competitive I am but I think it usually
works I heard a quote one time that says
if people in Hollywood aren't mad at you
you're not doing anything right then
yeah I guess so I I don't know I've
tried to be easy to work with I've tried
to be the person that people enjoy being
around and I think get a certain level a
lot of the CEOs are these huge companies
you know that that's when it gets to the
point where people are gonna be mad at
you one way or the other but right now I
feel like I'm in a good place I feel
like my company is in a good place
people respect what we do they find it
easy to work with us I think it's still
a service business at some point you're
providing somebody with a service so I
think it's important that you know you
treat people the right way and I don't
know hopefully people like me yeah I
actually meant it in a way that
sometimes people in this town resent
someone forgetting a project that they
didn't get or it's something like that
lemon I think that's true when there's
definitely some of that I don't do that
I think there's so much great work that
anytime somebody else gets something I
think it's great for them you know I'm
and it's not like I'm dying to have all
those other people's projects I I'm I
try and stay positive and I try and be
thankful for what I have and I try and
support other people and encourage them
as well so we need more than in Los
Angeles we do we do I saw an infographic
that talked about entrepreneurs and it
said that some of the traits were that
they were obsessive and that they kind
of had ideas that other people couldn't
understand but that's what set them
apart from other people do you think in
some sense the people that come here
maybe aren't obsessive enough they're
not competitive enough and then they
leave and go back home because they have
friends and family waiting for them
whereas if you have that sportsman
mentality where you almost have to win
that's gonna set you apart yeah I think
that is something that sets people apart
and I think anybody who's accomplished
anything really really amazing I mean
there's a few that are lucky but most
are not lucky it's just really hard work
and it's being competitive or being
intense and sacrificing and that's
really in any craft or trade I think you
know if you look at all the biggest
actors they're not the biggest actress
for no reason you know I worked with a
couple of them on this film Reese
Witherspoon
is a powerhouse you know she produces
she direct she acts she sings she does
everything and she's that successful
because number one she's smart and
really talented but there's thousands of
smart talented people she is driven and
I'm maybe I'm overstepping my bounds
because I'm not that close with her but
from what I have observed she's super
hard-working super smart super focused
and I'm sure somewhat competitive she
wants to win so I think that is
something that sets you apart
you